Rett chip type
Edwin's bid for re-election is in its
final stretch and campaigners are out in
force these women are going door-to-door
canvassing for the prime minister they
say should now become turkey's first
directly elected president Maryam Kara
Gersh is an experienced campaign
organizer and a longtime member of
Aaron's Justice and Development Party we
found a new unity under him and have
learned to get along better with one
another regardless of our convictions or
beliefs the women in this home don't
need any convincing some say they're
glad a Dewan lifted a ban on head
scarves at schools and universities
others praised his social policies I
didn't have a higher education but since
everyone's been in power I've been able
as a housewife to attend evening classes
and retake my final school exams
Edwin's Deputy Prime Minister has taken
a lot of flack for recently saying it
was unfitting for women to laugh loudly
in public but these are Diwan supporters
are paying no attention to the message
we feel like it we come from the Black
Sea where people laugh a lot a few
kilometers away opposition campaigns are
also in full swing women's rights
activists victory a yellow mass
distributes leaflets to raise awareness
about violence against women the
reported number of female murder victims
has risen more than tenfold since erawan
became prime minister these women say
the government doesn't protect women but
does try to control them the clothes I
wear if and when I get married the
number of children I have how I give
birth the government is against the
Syrians the state is gradually denying
women the right to make their own
decisions
Edda one voters should think again
they don't have to investigate a cliche
loud watch women voters appear evenly
divided on erawan some believe he's
championed their rights others feel he's
given them less of a say opinion polls
suggest every second woman will give ed
away and her vote he's taught us Turks
who we are and that Turkey is one of the
great powers in the world we don't want
to lose a politician of his caliber red
chip type air Dewan is the clear
favorite in Sunday's election thanks in
no small part to women